four days ago AOC said something really
dumb and wrong
that alone of course would not be
particularly newsworthy since the news
typically Endeavors to present stories
that are unusual but this particular
viral diatribe caught my attention not
because aoc's argument is wrong but
because
it is perfectly wrong take a listen
I think it's important to state that
that abortion is an economic issue
forcing poor and working-class people
to give birth against their will against
their consent against their ability to
provide for themselves or a child is a
profound economic issue and it's
certainly a way to keep a Workforce
basically conscripted to large-scale
employers and two employers to be to
work more against their will to take
second and third jobs against their
desire and their own autonomy and so the
idea that
um that abortion and access to abortion
is somehow not a profound and Central
economic and class issue and class
struggle is certainly something that I
think a person who's never had to
contend uh with the ability to carry a
child
um you know it belies that perspective
so aoc's argument is that abortion is an
important tool of the working class of
the proletariat to shake off the bonds
of its capitalist oppressors
but if that's the case
then how come all the big corporations
are subsidizing it
how come after the Dobbs decision came
down over ruling Roe v Wade how come
Google and Walmart and Amazon and pretty
much every big company in the country
sent out a press release promising to
reimburse the costs of female employees
who want to travel out of state to abort
their babies
abortion is a class issue but not in the
way AOC thinks actually in exactly the
opposite way abortion much like AOC is a
tool of wealthy capitalists to squeeze
more productivity and therefore more
money out of their labor force women who
have babies take more time off
during pregnancy during maternity leave
even after they come back to work if
they come back to work mothers are more
distracted with their kids doctor's
appointments and little league and piano
recitals and all the sorts of things
that make them less ideal as automatons
churning out widgets in the factory for
Big Boss Penny bags it's much much more
efficient
from a money standpoint for the
capitalists to just encourage the women
and even even pay the women to kill
their kids so that they can get back to
the office and do more spreadsheets if
AOC had an ounce of introspection she
might stop to ask herself why pretty
much all of the wealthiest and most
powerful people in the country support
her why she gets such glowing treatment
in the corporate press why she gets
invited to all of the fancy events with
all the rich people why AOC rakes in
more big dollar campaign donations than
pretty much any politician of her
stature in the country
if AOC were really a renegade radical
fighting the evil and entrenched
capitalist establishment wouldn't you
expect that that establishment might not
fawn over her constantly
in reality
AOC is no Renegade she's no radical she
is certainly no threat to the system the
system attacks and silences and
prosecutes the only real people who
question or oppose it which is to say
conservatives the system will throw
Midwestern grannies in jail for taking
selfies in the capital rotunda it'll
raid Donald Trump's home on bogus
charges if he gets a little bit too high
up in the polls for 2024 but it will
never go after AOC at least as long as
she continues as we see now to do its
bidding I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from Shaylin moon what
a what a name who says that happens to
my son all the time whenever he's with
someone he gets attention from other
girls but when he's been single they
don't show nearly as much interest he's
recently married with a new daughter
well that's good for him that's totally
true when I I think I mentioned this in
the context of dating advice but it's
true in all walks of life it's true
politically and everywhere else when you
are successful whether it means you got
a girlfriend or whether it means you're
winning elections or whatever when
you're successful that invites more
success because it is social proof that
uh you're you're someone worth investing
in so if you got a girlfriend then more
girls are going to show interest in you
because you seem successful and so these
other girls are going to look around
they're going to say oh well good enough
for that girl good enough for me maybe I
got to take another look at that guy
when you see a political team that is
winning and winning and winning that's
going to persuade more people huh maybe
that team is worth looking at maybe
they've got the right idea this is true
in all walks of life okay now when
you're talking whether it's to a girl or
to a boy or I don't know to your grandma
across the country you got to check out
pure talk right now go to puretalk.com
enter code Knowles the government is
addicted to spending it's not going to
stop and that Reckless spending is
driving up the costs on everything it's
not fair sure we can whine and complain
about it but we can also do something
about it there are things you can do
right now to lower your monthly expenses
and mitigate the impact of inflation
step one this should be a no-brainer
switch your cell phone service to Pure
Talk you are hemorrhaging money on your
cell phone bill if you even look at your
cell phone bill which I I used to not
even want to do okay but if you're with
Verizon ATT T-Mobile I know how much
you're paying you're paying too much
pure talk will give you unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just
thirty dollars a month that's not it not
thirty dollars plus another twenty
dollars plus another just thirty bucks a
month that could be a huge savings for
you and your family that's grocery money
that's gas money and Pure Talk never
raises their rates by switching to Pure
Talk the average family of four is
saving over 75 bucks every month
customers are realizing they just don't
need as much data as they thought join
the hundreds of thousands who are making
the switch to pure talk today when you
switch to pure talk with my special code
you will get 50 off your first month go
to puretalk.com choose your plan enter
code Knowles kwles for this special
offer that's puretalk.com enter code
Knowles Canada view less for 50 off your
first month
the the class struggle
pseudo communist rhetoric coming out of
the left is so silly it's so ridiculous
so much of our political system is just
so fake
and I think it's becoming clearer and
clearer Donald Trump in particular
exposed a lot of it as being so fake
that what we see is two sides locked in
the struggle the far left and the far
right and they're fighting each other
that it's it's really just kind of a
charade very often it's kind of just
political theater and no matter what
happens in these battles the system the
kind of liberal establishment system
just sort of always wins you see this on
on certain issues they don't change no
matter who wins the left wins the right
wins we get more and more immigration
and more and more illegal immigration
for that matter
the left wins the right winds we just
keep offshoring our jobs the left winds
the right winds we keep getting more
globalist government whether that means
through trade treaties or whether that
means through giving more of our
national sovereignty away it just
doesn't seem to whether the left wins or
the right wins we get the exact same
foreign policy a lot of it just seems
like a charade I don't think the
political battle in this country is
between the Communists on one side and
the fascists on the other side I think
it's between two slightly different
variations of liberals you see this with
Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi
who who came out and she said look we
need more mass migration because
not first because of Justice not first
because of these poor oppressed masses
yearning to be free but no because we
need someone to pick the crops
the fact is is that uh
we have a responsibility to secure our
border we also have a responsible to
recognize the importance of newcomers to
our nation right now the best thing that
we can do for our economy is to have
comprehensive immigration reform
and we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
but that doesn't mean that we
don't recognize our moral responsibility
as well
notice what she leads with
she she doesn't say we need more
migrants in this country because it's
the right thing to do or because
American foreign policy has destabilized
Latin America or because we're a Melting
Pot and we know she says we need more
workers
she's making a capitalist argument
AOC is Shilling on behalf of the
capitalists to get women to sit in their
offices and and stay in their jobs and
not have the temerity to want to raise a
family
that's why the capitalists fund all of
these people
the dominant power in this country that
conservatives need to fight against is
actually not the Communists or even the
Socialists they're a problem too but
they're a relatively minor problem the
problem is the Liberals the Menace in
our country is not is not Joseph Stalin
it's Bill Clinton okay it's neoliberal
kind of crony capitalist money money
money above all else to the destruction
of to the detriment and I think really
destruction of communities families the
traditional way of life our national
borders for goodness sakes everything
it's money
the libs want the open borders
they've got a whole lot of reasons for
one of the open borders they say they've
got social reasons they certainly have
political reasons and electoral reasons
but the reason they got a lot of oomph
behind it is because open borders is
good for the crony capitalists you know
it's not it's not the the commies
exactly
and conservatives I think we're figuring
this out now we've certainly been
figuring out a little bit more since
Trump we should not reflexively be
defending big corporations or even the
the free market as an as an end unto
itself markets are great market dynamics
can be a wonderful thing for economic
growth in a country but it's not the
be-all and end-all okay it's not an end
unto itself that would be putting the
cart before the horse the end of
government is Justice the end of
government is a flourishing Society
where we're all getting along and
growing and living together in in a good
country
okay we want we want the general welfare
we want the common good we want to live
in a nice place we were talking about
this a week or two ago you would much
rather be a poor man in a good Society
than a rich man in a society falling
apart
because even your wealth is contingent
on
the stability and flourishing of your
Society
okay if you're a rich man in Afghanistan
well you're probably not going to stay a
rich man very long because the Taliban
is going to show up and take your money
okay that that's that's what we need to
focus on here
we need to stop I I remember when I was
coming up in politics when I was a
teenager first kind of learning about
politics the the Republicans and the
conservatives they just carried water
for big corporations even when the
corporations attacked us even when they
started to censor us you heard arguments
from people ostensibly on the right who
said well you know we can't regulate
Google the most most powerful company on
Earth we can't regulate that if you want
to if you don't want to be censored and
kicked out of the Public Square and
you're a self-governing republic in your
formerly self-governing Republic then
just build your own Google yeah that's
that's a solution it's Preposterous and
it does nothing but Advance the
interests of what we would call the left
speaking of guys who just constantly
defend the liberal status quo
David French David French who we've
always gotten along personally well
enough uh but he he's
the Donald Trump era just
really radicalize this guy and so he was
always considered
a conservative or a right-winger we
wrote for right-wing outlets and things
but since Donald Trump he's been moving
further and further to the left I think
now you would call him a liberal writer
but but he still calls himself a
conservative writer and I think
I'm actually grateful to David's columns
I know a lot of conservatives just dunk
on David all the time
I am grateful for David French's columns
because they show you the chaos and
absurdity
that conservatives relatively recent
obsession with liberalism
and love affair with liberalism will
lead to
David French
just recently took to his blog
to make the conservative case for
transiting the kids
I'm not joking I'm not being hyperbolic
it's called when culture wars go way too
far he writes
I've always been conservative in the
left versus right context I've always
considered myself a man of the right the
Reagan right but when the extremes grow
more extreme in the classical liberal
structure of the American Republic is
under intellectual and legal attack
suddenly I'm an involuntary moderate
uh so I I think he's overstating the
classical liberal structure of the
American Republic I don't think America
was founded as some classical liberal
place I just gave a long speech on this
and read a long essay about this at the
daily wire I think that's made up I
think that's a completely retconned
revisionist history of America that took
place in the middle to late 20th century
and I think that America actually was
founded as a Christian Nation in the end
the evidence for that is pretty clear
for one you don't the word liberal just
doesn't appear in the founding documents
at all it doesn't appear in the
Constitution or the Declaration doesn't
appear even in the Federalists it
appears a handful of times in the
Federalist but then not referring to a
political philosophy only really
referring to the classical sense of the
word which means generous you know I was
very liberal with his wine or something
uh so anyway I think he's wrong on that
point but he might be sincerely wrong
there okay he thinks of himself as a man
on the right but
now he says because the right wing is so
extreme he's gone moderate he says it's
difficult to think of an exercise of
state power more raw immediate and
devastating than the use of state power
to sever the bond between parent and
child what is he talking about here
he's talking in part about Texas's
decision to classify transiting the kids
as child abuse that if you go and you
take a kid and you take the kid into a
doctor to put him on cross-sex hormones
or block his puberty or chop off his
genitals that that is a child abuse
and David says no no that's going too
far to suggest that parents can't Lop
off their kids genitals and pump them
full of the wrong hormones that's going
too far
he says it is a power to be exercised
sparingly in the most extreme cases it
is not a power to enlist in the culture
War over one of the emotional and
contentious contests of our time whether
or not to turn little children into
eunuchs at a time of profound public
Division and deep moral conflict
pluralism suffers from a serious
disadvantage compared to the illiberal
extremes of the far left and far right
it's not utopian by design it doesn't
own the libs he's talking about
pluralism here it doesn't own anybody it
accommodates dramatic differences in
world view the ill liberal extremes by
he thinks liberal is a good word when
referring to the political philosophy
the illiberal extremes by contrast offer
an alluring vision for their partisans
ultimate victory in the vanquishing of
their opponents
but when that Victory Sever's parent
from Child it's not only unjust it's
destabilizing I think it's much better
to sever a parent from the child that
that parent is abusing than to sever a
child from his genitals call me crazy
call me a radical call me illiberal
I think it's pretty clearly child abuse
to Lop off a child's genitals or to
start that process by putting them on
cross-sex hormones and puberty blockers
I think that's an abuse and whether
parents are doing that because they've
got Munchausen by proxy whether parents
are doing that because they sincerely
believe that's the right thing to do I
don't really care you've got to protect
the kid from that kind of abuse that
will destroy the kid's Body for Life
it's irreversible okay and it comes with
all sorts of other medical ailments that
are not even related directly to sex
and what it does
speaking again of the Crooked
capitalists
what it does is it puts these kids on a
lifelong subscription to pay oodles and
oodles of money to Big Pharma do you
think that might have something to do
with the explosion of transgenderism
forever younger groups of people you
think there might be some Financial
motives here since it's such a huge
Money Maker since we've got doctors on
record Public Health
uh leaders and administrators on record
who are saying you know these
transgender surgeries they're a big
money maker
it Matt Walsh in his expose of the
Vanderbilt transgender Clinic published
one of those videos just a couple of
weeks ago
of course
of course I am grateful to David's
Collins because if this is
if this is The Logical conclusion of
liberalism the kind of Classical
liberalism or right-wing liberalism or
whatever the people want to call it then
I'm out then I don't want it if the and
I think I think David's a very smart guy
actually and so people people mock him
now because he comes to these crazy
conclusions he's a very intelligent guy
and so if this is the conclusion that
liberalism leads to
then we got to get rid of liberalism
guys liberalism is bad it's not good
you've even in recent years that you've
heard this crazy line you heard people
say I'm a conservative because I'm a
liberal I don't know that's not me I'm a
conservative because I'm a conservative
I'm a conservative because I don't want
to lock kids generals off call me crazy
we need we obviously need an alternative
and in recent years political in the
last few decades politically there
really isn't an alternative it's a kind
of sock puppet game between you know AOC
and Pelosi they play the part of the far
left wing people and then David French
plays the part of the right-wing people
but the effect of their political
bickering is substantially the same
you're enriching the same
oligarchic crooked capitalist
corporations you're advancing the same
social policies AOC because she says
it's good to trans the kids David French
because he's saying it's so important to
our liberal structure that we must allow
in certain cases people to Transit kids
but what's the conclusion the conclusion
is that the kids get transced same thing
aoce calling for Mass migration and
conservatives saying well we can't stop
Mass migration that would be wrong
that's not who we are we need to we need
to be responsible and lose with dignity
and we can't really sent Deport people
or okay well what's the effect the
effect is mass migration
the libs pushing for all these kind of
transnational trade deals that give up
American sovereignty the conservatives
quote unquote conservatives saying well
you know free trade is a deeply
conservative value as of I don't know 20
years ago and uh so we've got to give up
all that sovereignty too but we're doing
it to not not for any political
Arrangement not because we love the UN
or the IMF or anything like that it's
because we want to make money okay well
what's the effect the effect is the same
thing
and and bizarrely
maybe not so bizarrely
all those kinds of policies are deeply
unpopular with the American people
right now go out and do a poll there
have been polls on this but go ahead do
a poll on the popularity of transiting
the kids
I promise you the vast majority of
Americans oppose translating the kids go
look at the popularity of
middle to late term abortion it's
extreme virtually no one supports late
term abortion among the American public
the ruling class does
the the Crooked capitalists do the the
libs who run everything they support it
but the people don't
who supports Mass migration the vast
majority of Americans according to a
recent Harvard Harris poll want to
drastically reduce illegal immigration
and legal immigration drastically reduce
it and yet the ruling class doesn't want
to do a thing about it on the left they
say we need more of all kinds of
immigration and on the right they don't
fix the illegal immigration problem and
then they say we need more legal
immigration but both both of those views
from the political class
are completely out of step with where
the American people are
and and the the result of both of them
of this kind of bickering between the
left and the right is basically just the
same policy
that's what we're fighting folks
and it's it's not
it's not uh anti-democratic or something
like that to say that liberalism has
gone way way too far we've let it run
roughshod over our country for far too
long no it actually to to say no to
liberalism would be a Vindication of
American democracy but unfortunately the
Liberals ensconce themselves in power
by pretending to speak on behalf of
democracy and whenever the whenever the
people don't want to go along with their
plans they just say well no no that the
people are trying to threaten democracy
oh no no when the majority of people
vote for some policy or vote for some
candidate that's too conservative they
say no no that's a that's a threat to
democracy oh no that Trump won the
election that's a threat to democracy oh
no Georgia Maloney won the election in
Italy that's a threat Victor orvan won
the election in Hungary that's a threat
to democracy
but this is the conclusion of it folks
the the religious writer the social
conservatives of the 1990s and 2000s
they have been Vindicated in absolutely
everything here's a headline from the
guardian
quote we are expected to be okay with
not having children
how gay Parenthood through surrogacy
became a Battleground
became a yeah I agree that shouldn't be
a Battleground we shouldn't even be
suggesting it how did it become a
Battleground became a Battleground
because the Liberals rammed it through
against the will of the people and
against right reason and against Justice
how gay Parenthood through surrogacy
became a Battleground
what does this say
s in New York a gay couple fighting to
make their insurers pay for fertility
treatment have found themselves in the
middle of a culture War what happens
when the right to Parenthood involves
someone else's body
what's
what is the right to Parenthood could
someone explain that to me I think
people people have a
you have a right to
Mary
or you have a right to you have a right
to do the right thing and getting
married is certainly the right thing
when you get married you do that to come
together for the sake of the generation
of an education of children now not
everyone gets kids
some people are infertile and that's
that's a great pain I've mentioned on
the show before sweet little Elise and I
have uh we spent a couple years dealing
with infertility
but
fortunately we were able to sort of you
know get around that with a few
different treatments we didn't because
we're Catholic we couldn't do IVF which
is the subject of this particular
article
but it was uh it was a real pain and so
I know that it's really hard for couples
who who are infertile and you can adopt
and you can do all sorts of other things
gay couples obviously do not have a
right to Parenthood because two men
can't make a baby and two women can't
make a baby but those people still have
the same natural longing for kids that
we all do
and so they want to get around it they
say well I have a right to Parenthood
but if you do if you you have a you
you have an obligation to deal with the
consequences of your actions and so if
you say okay I'm not going to get
married I'm going to live with if I'm a
man I'm going to live with another man
or if I'm a woman I'm going to live with
another woman then one of the
consequences of that is you're not going
to have kids
because the only people who can be truly
said have any rights in the context of
child birth and child rearing are the
babies here the babies who have a right
to their natural mother and father a
right to be the product of the conjugal
Act of their mother and father bound
together in marriage that is if we're
talking about rights in the abstract
that is the only real right that can be
said about
birth and parenting
now the libs don't like that
so this article goes on it's an
amazingly long article and these two
they say look it's illegal to to do gay
surrogacy in some places you know to go
out
purchase the egg of a woman and then
rent the womb of a poor woman
and then create a child in a Petri dish
and then implant that child probably
just freeze a bunch of the other
children that we create in a in a
freezer indefinitely and then plant that
child into the poor woman and then
eventually get that child and
intentionally deprive the child of his
natural mother
they're saying and it's hard for us to
do that of course that should be
completely illegal that's insane and
then it's amazing too what what the
article goes on to say
the article says that because this is
illegal in much of the United States and
much of Europe uh certain countries have
become tourist destinations for this
including Ukraine so Ukraine apparently
though it's I think officially still
illegal
to do gay commercial surrogacy in
Ukraine they do permit commercial
service generally
and apparently according to this article
Ukraine has become a hot spot Center for
same-sex couples to go rent a womb and
create a child through surrogacy and
then they said but when the war broke
out this was this was really awful
because people's babies that they had
created and implanted in these poor
women's wombs they were locked away in a
war zone can you imagine
yeah that's horrible the whole thing is
so insanely dystopian
none of this should be happening
whatsoever
they say the phrase they use they say
when the Ukraine war broke out these gay
couples in the west well they saw that
their Precious Cargo was still in in
Ukraine which made me wonder
how come a baby is precious cargo when
that baby is desired by Rich gay men but
the baby is merely a clump of cells when
the baby is not desired by his mother
isn't that kind of weird
how that how the baby changes like that
depending on who wants the baby that
seems a little crazy
this is the problem with the slippery
slope I don't even blame the gay men who
are confused by this or who haven't
thought this through or who naturally
desire a child it makes perfect sense
but this is the slippery slope
when you
redefine marriage in this absurd way and
pretend that two men can be married to
one another where two women can be
married to one another
then you are saying that the union of
two men is the same as the union of a
man and a woman
and so if when we're talking about
marriage obviously married couples have
a a right to procreate
now gay men can't procreate with one
another so then the the law has to go
along come behind and sort of
change to accommodate this fiction that
there's such a thing called same-sex
marriage so they'll do that by
permitting homosexual adoption and
they'll do that by permitting surrogacy
and IVF and renting a womb in Ukraine
and they'll do this through all sorts of
things that are completely immoral that
are com that are really heinous that are
really awful
and a child abuse
and they're destructive for society but
that Advance a liberal paradigm
this is the slippery slope this is why
they say oh who cares why does it matter
why does it matter if two people want to
get married first of all again it's not
the issue is redefining marriage who
cares if we fundamentally redefine the
basic social institution basic political
institution well I don't I don't know
because now we've got
poor babies being created to be deprived
of their natural mother in war zones
because of what not because of Communism
not because of socialism because of a
hyper capitalist system where now human
beings are Commodities where now you are
purchasing a womb and you're by the way
I'm referring to a womb you're not even
purchasing the woman you're not viewing
the woman as a real woman you're viewing
the woman as nothing but a vessel to be
rented and purchased for your interests
and desires
so that you can purchase a child a child
is no longer the product of love between
his parents and the personification of
that love the child is just another
commodity to be purchased like a Prada
handbag or a Rolex watch
except except slightly more expensive
actually in the case of of surrogacy and
IVF
that's hideous but it's not just the
commies it's not just the far leftist
it's not it's it's a it's a perversion
of it's an extreme version of capitalism
divorced from any moral order
and the conservatives have utterly
failed to fight against that because
we've been tilting at windmills against
Joseph Stalin and Vladimir Lenin the
problem lies a little bit closer to home
I think
speaking of
hyper capitalism and Ukraine actually I
mentioned a piece on Friday by
Christopher Caldwell who's a terrific
cultural writer and it was in The
Claremont review books
the article was on why are we in Ukraine
and it was I felt a pretty Fair article
on
how we ended up in this war in Ukraine
and this kind of proxy war with Russia
and how the Ukraine war broke out just a
little bit of a history of it because
the war didn't just break out earlier
this year it's been building for a long
time there's been some version of this
war going on for about eight years now
and the the tensions in that region of
the world go back about a thousand years
so he gave a decent
a very good I think overview of it but
there's a really interesting observation
he made
which is the role of Corporations
in that war you think about early on in
that in the after the Russian invasion
of Ukraine Elon Musk offered to to use
his starlink satellite system to give
the ukrainians internet and allow them
to coordinate communicate
and this was hailed as a wonderful thing
and for the ukrainians it certainly was
a wonderful thing and for stopping
Russian aggression it certainly was a
wonderful thing
but it also means them
that an ostensibly private Corporation
became a belligerent in the war
the the U.S Congress or the Ukrainian
Congress or whatever didn't didn't vote
or NATO or the EU none of those people
voted to send Elon musk's Machinery into
Ukraine he just did it he's just a
wealthy guy he's just a capitalist and
he did it Ian bremmer who's a well-known
writer especially in foreign policy he
said that SpaceX Microsoft and Google
have become quote literal belligerence
in the war
and he said that this was a wonderful
thing he said they were creating a world
in which corporations and banks have
quote a hell of a lot more impact in
what the global outlook on climate will
be than any government so he was turning
his attention not just from the war in
Ukraine but on climate change and all
the rest of these political initiatives
but think about that if these
corporations are literal belligerents in
the war
then there then they're the ones waging
the war then they become Targets in the
war then all of a sudden Russia might
decide to send a missile to not just to
the capital not just to an American
Military Target but to SpaceX
headquarters or to Google Headquarters
maybe they're going to send it over to
Palo Alto
and then if the corporations are the
ones that are the literal belligerents
in the war that are waging the war then
that means they're making the Strategic
decisions on how to wage the war but war
is a serious business
that's why in the United States
at least according to the Constitution
to go to war
the Senate needs to vote for it it's not
even just the president the president is
the commander-in-chief of the military
but to declare war you need to bring in
the legislature we're not supposed to do
this willy-nilly we're supposed to take
this very very seriously now it's not
won't be the legislature it won't even
be the president won't even be the
commander-in-chief it's going to be
these corporations outside of the
government but if the corporations are
powerful enough to wage war
certainly if the corporations are
powerful enough to control the Public
Square in what is ostensibly our
Republic if there are if they can not
only silence you they can silence the
duly elected sitting president of the
United States Donald Trump on January 7
2021. if the if the corporations can do
that outside of the government
then the corporations are the government
the daily wire is hiring a senior
front-end web developer to join our
streaming platform and e-commerce team
you need at least three years of real
world software experience but you do not
need a college degree just big league
coding chops in Big Bang Theory speak
you got to be Adept in HTML5 css3
JavaScript react native and restful apis
I'm pretty pretty strong on Minesweeper
and I did Visual Basic one so I'm maybe
I'll apply for this job and we'll
compete with one another if front-end
web development is your love language
apply to join us in Nashville where you
will upgrade the user experience and
Beauty not just of our streaming
platform but more importantly of my
section on The Daily wear website it
could use a facelift we need it now
let's do it go to dailywire.com careers
to apply today also the daily wire is
hiring a senior vice president of
marketing and analytics data and
operations wow
it's a lot of responsibility I'm told
that this is a high profile executive
role with paid relocation to Nashville
this innovator will Design hire and
oversee a world-class marketing data and
analytics team that has built atop the
marketing data stack from CRM platforms
to multi-touch attribution tools what
the hell do any of these words mean to
propensity targeting models okay
whatever this leader will for example
study which daily wire shows and films
most interest the audience and also
which daily wire host is the most
annoying and I think we all know the
answer to that
rhymes with Mr blenn blopiro now don't
you say it's me don't you dare tell them
that it's me so if you understand what a
full marketing data and analytics stack
is head on over to dailywire.com careers
apply now
that was a lot that was a that was a lot
we're hiring so many people
speaking of of big Tech and censorship
we have
less and less control over our
government
in a world in which the corporations can
decide what's allowed to be said in the
Public Square in a world in which the
corporations can literally wage war
according to Ian bremmer
then then unless unless you're a major
stakeholder in Microsoft or or Amazon
then you have even less control over the
government than you did under our old
system of government
here's a case in point this drove me
crazy
it is a headline it's all throughout the
media right now it says FBI's brutal
draft letter firing disgraced agent
Peter strzok revealed
we're all covering it and and there's
there are some people on Twitter on
social media they say wow owned oh yeah
yeah this is brutal oh yes suck it
Peter struck yeah we're gonna show you
he says while there is no doubt your 21
years of service to the organization
cannot and should not be erased it is
difficult to Fathom the repeated
sustained errors of judgment you made
while serving as the lead agent and two
of the most high profile investigations
in the country Peter struck you corrupt
left-wing anti-trump FBI you remember he
was the really corrupt FBI agent who who
went after Trump through the office of
the Inspector General although the
office of the Inspector General found no
evidence of bias impacted any of you or
the FBI's investigative actions or
decisions your sustained pattern of bad
judgment in the use of an FBI device has
been called into question for many of
the decisions that you made in short
your repeated selfishness has called
into question The credibility of the
entire FBI
take that how do you like that Peter
struck it's a strongly worded letter
that's great that's great
I'm so glad we're the party of the
strongly worded letter
that's that's what the conservatives are
the conservatives we are the we are the
party of the strongly worded letter and
the left is the party of the firing
squad
but we got oh did you see we got some
total Burns in there Zing owned take it
hmm
and it's true Peter struck did get fired
he's trying to sue now and trying to say
it was wrongful a politically motivated
termination and who knows it'll probably
he'll probably get something out of it
too
but okay Peter struck gets fired
did the FBI get cleaned up
the FBI
which colluded directly with the
Democrats with Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats to spy on the Republican
Presidential nominee when he was running
in 2016 and then to undermine his entire
Administration based on absolutely
nothing
just completely cooked up political
operation did did the FBI get cleaned up
at all other than this guy sort of got
pushed out a little bit
no the FBI is still doing the same thing
the FBI is still going after parents who
are concerned about their kids being
taught critical race theory in schools
and and being Trans in kindergarten the
FBI is going after those people the FBI
is going after Pro attacking pro-lifers
right now in America the FBI is rating
the home of the former president and
chief political rival to Joe Biden just
coincidentally I'm completely bogus
charges
no the FBI's gotten worse
yeah not only not only did we not clean
up the FBI by firing this loser Peter
strzok
he's probably gonna get something out of
the government when he sues them
and the FBI itself is worse than ever
but we but we feel really good boom
owned we wrote you a mean letter how do
you like that they like it just fine
yeah we write them a mean letter and we
show them what jerks they are and then
they keep wielding power over us that's
what happens
I would much rather be the party of just
political efficacy
I would much rather be the party of
winning and and actually fixing things
about our culture
then the party of like really really
zingy letters
I don't I've had enough of the strongly
worded letters we need to do something
it's so pathetic they're just rubbing
our noses in it now
did you you remember Peter daziak
I talk about Peter dashak in my fauchy
unmasked series which you can get at
Daily wire plus right now uh it's best
you should especially get it now uh
because uh it goes through the history
of Dr fauci and the corruption on our
Public Health System taxpayer funded and
uh and the corruption that we're still
seeing today in many cases it's getting
worse so Peter daziak
is this Maniac who was doing gain of
function research through his group Eco
Health Alliance he was doing
taxpayer-funded Government research on
bat coronaviruses all the sort of
dangerous research that would seem most
likely to be very connected with the
outbreak of the wuflu
and Dr fauci initially denied that he
had ever funded Peter daschak on this
particular kind of research and then he
said that to the United States Senate
then it turned out that was a total lie
that actually we have we have the grand
Dr fauci funded hundreds of thousands of
dollars of research on this kind of
stuff uh to Peter two Eco Health
Alliance so you'd think okay after the
covid thing
this guy's career is over right
certainly he's not getting any more
Government funding
certainly he can't there's a guy who was
doing research at the Wuhan Institute of
virology certainly sure at the very
least this guy isn't not getting
Government funding to do research on
that coronaviruses right
no he just got more money
he just got some more money he just got
653
392 dollars for Eco Health Alliance
Incorporated to begin September 21st
2022 so
you know 20 18 days from now
to do research on
on these sorts of viruses
we we know
that in all likelihood
it was this kind of research that led to
the outbreak of covid according to
Justin B Kinney who's an associate
professor at Cold Spring Harbor
laboratory Princeton PhD he said the
this evidence is not dispositive
but were the lab leak hypothesis
incorrect it would represent a
staggering set of coincidences this I
think is the the biggest
effect of covid this is the biggest side
effect of covid and really certainly the
biggest side effect of the covid
vaccines coincidences you know just so
many coincidences as a result of all of
this
no consequences here
plenty of coincidence is no consequences
even Peter dashek he became it was a big
political issue we raked fauci over the
coals remember Rand Paul grilled Dr
fauci was great it was great TV
it was good stuff I applaud Rand Paul
for doing it for calling attention to
this I I think that my series fauci
unmasked is very important stuff sheds
all the light on this stuff
but where is the political power
I'm
I'm just a guy with a microphone
I do not currently hold any political
office
maybe I should I don't know I think I
think 2022 is going to be a good year
it's probably a little late to throw my
hat in now but I I can't change the
policy right now
I can just call attention the people who
have political power the ones that can
change the policy where are they
why can't we do that
I'm not even casting aspersions on the
on the Senators and the congressmen and
in many cases they don't have the power
to do that either because the political
system
is dominated by the libs even when the
Republicans win the house even when
Republicans win the Senate even when
Republicans win the White House we had
Unified Government for a while under
Trump
but we don't control the executive
agencies we don't control the
corporations that have taken more and
more and more power and can literally
wage war and can censor even the
president of the United States
and how did those corporations get all
that power
in part the left let them have it in
part the right the right let him have it
but either way
those guys aren't on our those
capitalists aren't on our side and then
of course the universities and then of
course the media which is just corporate
media anyway and on and on and on it's
very very difficult
in this political
structure to really get anything done
and whenever people pose any threat to
the political structure they get taken
out not AOC she gets invited to the Met
Gala she gets she gets put on the cover
of all the magazines and all the glossy
photos and all the newspapers but when
any ever anyone raises any real
objections to this sort of a system that
that person is suppressed
there's no question about it you're
seeing this Dynamic right now the no
consequences Dynamic play out on the
transgender issue there's a high school
in Vermont
it's cracking down right now after
female students complained about a dude
who thinks that he's a woman in the in
the girl's locker room
so girls complain they say look we don't
want to get naked in front of this guy
we don't want this guy getting naked in
front of us that's why we have a girls
locker room right
and the school says okay we're going to
do something about this
girls you're no longer allowed in the
locker room
I'm not joking
this is being reported by CBS affiliate
uh WCAX they said okay the way we're
going to deal with this uh transgender
lady you know this guy who's dressed up
like a lady you get to use the girl's
locker room and the girls on the team
they have to change individually in a in
a single bathroom so they got to take
turns in this one single bathroom to get
changed because they the great fear
would be
you know that this transgender student
we're being bullied by being asked to
leave the girls room and not not get
naked in front of the girls
why is the school doing this
it's not because this is what the
parents want
it's not
it's not because this is popular it's
not public opinion is totally against
this ever if you go out on the street
right now you talk to 100 people 92 of
those people are going to tell you this
is completely insane transgenderism is
bogus certainly at the very least guys
should not be allowed in a girls room so
why is this permitted
because
the the ruling class wants it to happen
the people with the power
in in our government
in the corporations in the media in the
press and all over
in in Academia
these people
who have this kind of power they are
pushing transgenderism and why I I
actually have some theories as to why
along the lines of the sort of financial
thesis of today's show we don't have
time to get to it right now but we we
can get to it at a later date how's that
for a teaser we do have more show coming
up though what we've got to get to is uh
a rap a rap song from a Utah State
Senate candidate a republican Utah State
Senate candidate I have never heard this
rap song before but it's music Monday
so my producer Ben Davies has has lined
up this song for me I can't wait to
listen to it that show is continuing
right now you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click on the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]